hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
uh paul charles morphe vs thomas wilson
barnes uh and uh
well this is a game you will simply not
believe i already made a video on this
game but it was some three years ago
uh so we are going to remake it at 60
frames per second
uh and well it's also now a part of the
saga so
i'm gonna leave that video to be like a
standalone video sort of a reminder of
how the channel looked sometimes
long long long time ago and we are going
to now remake it as
it's uh well it is an enjoyable game so
morphe uh opens
with e4 and uh barnes
goes for none other than f6 sorry about
that
and believe it or not this move is
actually called the barnes
defense and it's called the barnes
defense for a good reason
but we'll get back to that uh and uh as
well
usually you don't want to play six ever
and you you don't want to play f6 on the
first move
so morphe just continues by grabbing the
center he says okay barnes you do your
stuff i'm just gonna
claim the entire center for myself uh
with
e6 by barnes now preparing 97 and d5 so
it's sort of a
long preparation of striking in the
center bishop to d3 by morphe
and knight to e7 now we have bishop to
e3
and it is as of move 4 that this
position has never been reached again
we have d5 barnes strikes in the center
and the knight the c3
of course morphe as usual favors the
development above all
we have d captures knight captures and
now knight to d5 so grabbing
the d5 square for his knight and also
waiting
well if c for dangerous knight captures
on e3 is the idea
and here i don't know i i if i was
playing white i would like
move the bishop right away i would not
give up the bishop pair just like that
but morphy goes knight to h3 he says
okay i'm just gonna continue my
development the queen to h5 will be
a possibility uh and so on so bishop to
e7
and morphe goes for it bishop to h5
check but barnes isn't worried barnes
goes g6
he pushes morphy's queen back we have
queen to h6 or in this case forward
uh now uh stopping castle and preparing
queen to g7 so barnes goes bishop back
to f8
and with this little maneuver what
barnes has done
is that well he freed the g7 square for
his bishop and now he's going to play
bishop g7 and castle king's side
so morphy goes back we have uh queen to
h4 and now comes
bishop to g7 just preparing the castle
we have castles by white and the castles
by black and here
uh here is a great opportunity for
morphe to go bishop to h6
just uh black created a lot of dark
square weaknesses
and bishop to h6 does make sense you do
want to eliminate black's dark square
bishop however murphy goes for c4 here
uh he attacks the knight and well he he
improves his
central control but he gives up the dark
square bishop and now black's dark
square bishop is
uh free to roam unopposed so to say so f
captures on e3 and now
f5 uh opening up uh the bishop's
diagonal opening up an attack on the
queen the knight is under attack
and morphy needs to figure out what to
do here he goes knight eg5 now threatens
checkmate
but barnes says uh just h6 takes care of
all of my troubles we have knight back
to f3
and now even e5 barnes now gets rid of
his uh
weak e6 pawn and now there are a lot of
threats well
the queens are still uh up for a trade
e4 is coming and well there's just uh
a lot of things here uh then now morphe
decided to trade queens here however
there was the very sneaky c5 idea
c5 point being that if you go for e for
now you have bishop to c for
check and when the king moves 95 and now
the point is even if black captures the
queen now you have knight g6 check you
pick up a pawn and
win back your queen so there were little
tricks like that in the position it's
not a forced line but it is a very fun
line so i i decided to show it
morphe instead went for bishop cap queen
captures on d8
uh with rook captures on d8 and now
bishop back to c2
so here we have uh e captures on d4 and
with this little maneuver now
uh barnes was able to win a pawn so e
captures and bishop captures on d4
with check so morphy captures and now
rook captures on d4
so barnes is up upon and uh what
what does morphe have to show for it
well barnes is kind of undeveloped for
the moment
so rook fe1 morphe claims the open e
file for his rook and now
king to f7 barnes says no you are not
getting rook to e7 i know how to play an
end game
uh morphy goes c5 save his saves his
pawn on c4
also morphe's trying to trick barnes
into something like rook c4 to go after
the pawn and then morphy can just trap
the rook
but barnes uh is no stranger to chess
himself he just goes bishop to e6
uh closes this diagonal and now comes
rook a to d1 so full development for
morphe
but barnes doesn't care uh you could go
for real captures on d1
also a possibility for example if
captures captures uh morphe was maybe
hoping for bishop captures an e2 but
then you get rook to d8 and the white
definitely will have compensation uh but
you definitely don't want to try b3 here
to try and trap the bishop
because you simply can't knight a6 rook
a1 and then
knight to b4 uh saves the black
everything and
there is no more no more trying for
white here
so instead after rookie to d1 barnes
just continues developing pieces so nice
to see six
and now comes uh rook captures on d4 so
morphe trades a pair of rooks we have
knight captures and the bishop to a4
but now g5 taking away the f4 square
from morphe's knight we have rook to d1
and now comes rook to d8 uh defending
the knight
with some well okay for the moment the
bishop guards the rook but you have to
be careful so you don't run into some
sort of a discovery check and then you
lose your rook
so here we have a3 preparing to uh
make this structure very solid after
pushing b4 and now
f4 from barnes now opening up this
bishop's diagonal
you do not want to allow this capture so
knight f2 by
morphe and now knight to e2 with check
here
uh barnes successfully uh trades off the
remaining rook and goes into a
a an end game of minor pieces so king f1
by morphe and now
rook captures on d1 with check bishop
captures and knight e4 and here
we have a bishop against the knight
versus a bishop against tonight with
uh six points barnes and five pawns
morphy so can morphy hold this being
down upon
well let's see let's see what happens
here uh we have uh
kinked e1 uh and okay morphe starts
bringing the king into the game
uh with king to f6 barnes does the same
with
knight the uh king to d2 and now
uh barnes sees an opportunity here and
goes for it knights the b3 check checks
the king and forks the c5 pawn
so morphe has to take the knight in
order to save the pawn so bishop
captures bishop captures
and now morphy has a knight against the
bishop still down a pawn with knight g4
check
going after the h6 pawn king to g6 by
that's not g6 king to g6 by barnes
uh and now g3 by morphy trying to
trade out some of the pawns but uh like
we
mentioned barnes is no stranger to the
end game himself
uh he pushes h5 he says uh move your
knight back we have knight f2 and now
king f5 uh he wants morphy to capture so
he can capture with the king and
uh have his two pawns uh connected like
this
so king c3 morphe improves the position
of the king goes after the bishop bishop
d5 now
we have king to d4 and not just c6
solidifying that bishop on d5 with b4 by
morphe
and now you could have some ideas of
maybe pushing b5
which would make the the bishop weak so
barnes just moves it bishop to g2
he wants to play the bishop all the way
to f1 to keep an eye on the b5 square
all the way from behind
and here yeah morphe for the lack of a
better move
goes g captures an f4 uh we have king
captures
uh and now a4 so uh trying to get
b5 in but now just bishop to f1 by
barnes
we have knight to e4 by morphe now comes
h4 preparing g4
and g3 we have knight back to d2 by
morphe going after the bishop
bishop to e2 now we have knight back to
e4
and now just g4 by barnes morphy goes
knight back to f2
and now king to f3 again uh kicking the
knight away
uh if you just push g3 then you can
capture and put the knight on h3 this
way
barnes makes sure that morphe will not
have any such trickery allowed
knight back to e4 and here uh here is a
good question
uh do you push g3 right away or not well
barnes didn't because if you push it
right away you're still winning of
course but you allow whites to give up
the night and then you can
sort of make his uh life a bit difficult
you know
you're gonna make him work for his meal
uh so instead
barnes just goes bishop to f1 and here
with this bishop to f1 move
uh he puts morphe in in sort of a two
trunk as
there isn't much you can do you cannot
play b5 the bishop and pawn guard that
square if you play a5
then you're never playing b5 again you
can't move the king
away from the defense of the knight
because you lose the knight and you
cannot move the knight because g3 just
wins then
so what do you do well the only thing
possible king the e5
uh just keep keep an eye on that knight
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the easiest
way to win this game for mr barnes while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on beating paul
charles murphy
by playing f6 on the first move and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's bishop to d3 and this is the
simplest way to win
uh because you're just threatening to
pick up the knight and if the knight
moves
you've removed the defender of the g3
square you're just gonna push g3
and that's it so this is what barnes
played morphe continued knight g5 check
now king g2
so not much to do you're picking up the
spawn and then just uh
starting to push the pawns uh morphe of
course goes after the queen side pawn so
there still is some play here
king captures on h2 king c7 and now king
to g3 making room for the h
pawn morphy grabs the b7 pawn and now
comes
h3 and it was in this position that paul
charles morphe resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh point is that after you try and
create a pass pawn let's say b5
white black will capture and now c6 uh
yes it is a very past past
a fast pass c pawn but after h2 and c7
h1 comes
with a queen check and there is there's
no continuing this after this
king moves uh you can play bishop f5
guard the queening square and it's just
all over black has a queen why doesn't
so morphe of course knew all of this and
after age three uh he resigned
the game so it's a i thought it's a
really an interesting game
of course the first time i i covered it
uh we
we did it a bit differently so if you
haven't seen that video uh
you know i will put a link to it in the
description below if you want to see how
the channel looked
way long long time ago uh but yeah i
also hope you enjoyed this one because
usually
there's a saying like never play f6 like
never especially not on move one but
here
barnes played it and he defeated paul
charles morphy with the black pieces
playing f6 on the first move really
crazy stuff
i thought the quote above the board was
fitting uh says uh who is your opponent
tonight tonight i'm playing against the
black pieces
usually attributed to uh to i think uh
bogalubov but
as as i'm not sure uh some sources say
uh that it it doesn't say who who said
it some say blue or some say tarash
uh but you know sometimes i write tara
sometimes i write
uh but yeah uh it doesn't matter if your
opponent plays f6 on the first move or
whenever you still have to play a good
game and beat the position
not the the gentleman well morphy
obviously didn't think much of barnes as
he really just
launched forward adam and he thought
yeah we're just going to crush him now
that he played f6 but that's not how
chess works
so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it
uh do share it with your friends at the
bar in the library i would like to thank
anastasias
brian hughes carlos felipe alfonso de
mora and now i'll chopra for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
twice as we missed it in the previous
video and i will see you soon